The Republic of Korea is the 15th largest economy in the world...
...and the fourth largest in Asia.
The economy is booming, and there's never been a better time to be here.
This is a high-tech society with a tech savvy culture.
Most Koreans spend at least two hours a day on the Internet,...
...and home shopping is extremely popular.
More than 125 British companies such as Standard Chartered, TESCO, Veritas, and Diageo...
...have a presence in Korea.
Opportunities exist for British companies in many sectors.
The Republic of Korea has a vibrant ICT industry...
...and makes leading edge flat screens, mobile phones and PCs.
And the flat screen supply chain, the UK company, Edwards,...
...will spruce up a manufacturing plant in Korea...
...to be near to Samsung, its main supplier.
President Lee's Low Carbon Green Growth Strategy...
...means opportunities for British designers in building sustainable buildings...
...as well as those in the low carbon supply chain.
The EU-Korea Free Trade Agreement...
...will radically alter the way we do business with Korea.
97 percent of tariffs will fall away within three years.
Some will fall away on implementation.
The service sector will also benefit.
There has never been a better time to do business in Korea.